WE GET SET OF THE NET.
SABRES KEEPING IT IN CENTER ICEE
SHOT, THEY SCORE!
SHOT
DEFENDER.
HE IS GOING BACK IN WITH HIM.
ONE GOES WIDE OF THE NET.
>> ON IN TO THE CORNER FOR
LARKIN. DOWN ON ET IT BACK AGAI
AND THEY KEEP IT IN THERE, AND
THERE'S A CHANCE IN FRONT.
NEDJELKOVIC MAKES THE SAVE.
THAT WAS KNOCKED BEHIND IN TO T
YOUU GOING DOWN
THE RIGHT SIDE.
YOU SEE THE PUCK SEE IF
THE LINESMAN ARE OVER AT THE
BOX.
THEY ARE LOOKING
HERE'S THE CALL.
>> Referee: A IN AGAIN BY THE R
TRYING TO WORK IT IN FRONT OF
GETTING IT THROUGH.
>> TRYING TO IT, SIDE BROKEN UP
AND
DETROIT.
BUFFALO LOOKING TOBRES.COM.
>> TO YOUSCORED.
JEFFRJ, THE
SPINNING JEFF SKINNER AND HE
WILL BE THE
THE FACE-OFF, CONTROLLING BERTU.
OVERTIME.
COMING THROUGH FOR THE WITH
THE WINGS, GOT IT IN OVER THE
BURT SIDE AND
DETROIT WINS IT IN THE